we have a tradition here on the New
Year's Eve show yes it's the moment
you've all been waiting for it's time
for Party Pieces everyone Catherine what
have you brought us but I found this
very intimidating and I think I think I
can make a noise like a baby cry it's a
party
[Applause]
I did only try this out today
[Music]
[Applause]
underselling it meant some money it's
forced to dredge that up I wish my my
little boy was that quiet when he
returned guy Pierce the pride of
Australia the pride of Australia what
are you going to be well in the spirit
of Priscilla I thought perhaps I'll give
you some of the Opera
top of the bus you're gonna sing some of
the top of the box aria
okay look I'm a little croaky I'm croaky
your throat moment okay but we'll see if
we can remember okay okay
Foley Foley delivery of a Norquist Oh Oh
abandon Hara in questa Peloso desert
yokel a nobody knew how to let a Sempron
why la vie de ville love me open
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow baby crying when I do that to him at
home though the party peace pressure has
rolled down the couch okay keira
knightley this is good wait for this I
can play my teeth can play raindrops
keep falling on my hair I mean I can
play anything you want but like much
going with raindrops you've chosen that
song I'm wearing a jacket where I can't
quite bend my arms so I think this mic
will pick it up okay okay wait a minute
Oh haven't done this in a while so this
is just a Roger this is ahead performed
on her teeth take it away yeah
that
Wow what does your dentist think about
that
[Music]
you